new autopsy results released on the
driver authorities say caused a deadly
six-car crash in north las vegas earlier
this year those autopsy reports showing
that 59-year-old gary robinson had a
significant amount of cocaine in his
system christian casarez joining us live
this evening he is in our newsroom with
what else those reports found well brian
and denise the reports were released
today now the autopsy and toxicology
reports not only found cocaine but also
pcp and alcohol in robinson's system
it's been weeks since that horrific
deadly weekend crash in north las vegas
but now new details about the driver who
allegedly caused it according to the
clark county coroner gary dean
robinson's autopsy shows the 59-year-old
died of blunt force injuries but had a
large amount of cocaine among other
illegal substances in his body at the
time of the crash
urine and blood tests found cocaine pcp
and alcohol in robinson's system autopsy
and toxicology reports said
on january 29th the north las vegas
resident was driving a dodge challenger
police say he ran a red light driving
more than 100 miles per hour at commerce
street and cheyenne avenue both robinson
and his female passenger 46-year-old
tanaga miller died people had pay
attention that crash also killed seven
members of the zacarias family that were
traveling inside this toyota minivan
including four children two stepsons and
a brother their parents speechless but
grateful for the outpour of community
support helping raise a hundred thousand
dollars through a gofundme account
the eight news now i-team also learning
robinson pled guilty for speeding up to
10 miles per hour over the speed limit
in early december of last year where
according to court records he paid a 150
dollar fine christian casa is live local
now